- Hey, guys, welcome. Good afternoon.
This is really awesome.
We are super excited
with this customer panel.
We have an exciting session for you.
If I can advance the slide
and it's very (indistinct)
to what we have been
listening in at the keynote.
How many of you were able
to watch Matt's keynote this morning?
So you, oh wow. This more than I thought.
So you heard about AI infrastructure
and how we are optimizing,
you heard about AI factory,
there was a Trainium
3 launch, it's now GA.
He talked about UltraClusters
and UltraServers.
So we have a distinguished
panel of speakers.
We have Andrea Klein Director
of Engineering at Arm.
We have Henri Dwyer,
Senior Director of
Engineering at Genentech
and we have Shaunak Godbole who
is a field CTO at Fireworks.
And what we really like you
to take away from this session
is when you go back
home you should be armed
with some tips and tricks and mechanisms
in how you can scale your AI applications
using AWS's infrastructure and our stack.
And so we have a framework
that seems to work.
The agenda is really that
I'll set up the framework.
We think about scaling
AI in terms of scaling up
in terms of TFLOPS and memory
and memory bandwidth.
Scaling out in terms of
increasing the number of GPUs
and servers and
UltraClusters and clusters.
And then scaling across
the inference stack.
And each of the speakers
will actually index on that.
Andrea will talk about her
experiences scaling out.
She'll talk about fault
detection and observability tools
and how, you know, what
you need to pay attention
to when you scale out to thousands of GPUs
and thousands of clusters.
Henri will talk about scaling up.
He has a very interesting application
around molecular dynamics.
So a lot of LLMs but also
a lot of spatial coding.
And he'll end with agentic AI.
Genentech is actually using agentic AI
for what they call lab in the loop.
So this will be a very
interesting thing to hear from.
And that's actually a good
segue to Shaunak's session
where he's going to talk
about the principles
of building agentic AI
and how they have been able
to optimize across each layer
of the stack at the hardware
layer, model, frameworks,
and runtime layer to get what,
10 plus trillion tokens per day.
So he'll talk about more on that.
I'll let them introduce themselves.
Fireworks also has a booth so Shaunak
will have more details.
Alright, so without further ado.
So when I think of scaling
up and scaling out,
there are two workloads that come up
front and center and I
spend most of my days
working with accelerate compute
and understanding customer's
needs around AI and around HPC.
So AI as we think of frontier models,
a hundred billion plus models,
they of course need a lot of compute,
but even smaller models
that are more network latency sensitive
like video and image models,
they require scaling up
and scaling out in terms of inferencing,
especially around aggregated inferencing
if you're serving batch mode inferencing
but also real time where
latency is critical,
this becomes important.
And the reason it becomes
important is these models
are processing huge, massive
amounts petabytes of data
and doing massive amounts
of parallel computing
and scientific calculations.
So that's why scaling on
infrastructure becomes important
and where AWS spends, like our team spends
every single day talking to customers.
And that reminds me, I
forgot to introduce myself.
So I'm Principal Specialist
in our GenAI accelerated compute team.
So everything to do with
accelerated compute.
One of the hardware layers
that I'll talk about
comes through our team,
Trainium and Inferentia of course,
but NVIDIA GPUs and other GPUs,
that's what we deal with day in day out.
And then HPC also has
some interesting quirks.
They have both tightly coupled
and loosely coupled workloads.
And I've had the fortune of
working in a (indistinct),
Henri will talk about his
protein folding use case.
So these use cases also
lead to large amount
of scale requirements.
And so if I dive deep
into one of the workloads,
if you think of training,
these are typically episodic workloads.
They take a few weeks to a few months,
but they're tightly coupled.
Often when they ask for GPUs from us,
they ask for a single AZ.
In fact they ask for a single spine.
And one of the reasons why
we introduced UltraServers
that you heard at the keynote
is because even a single
spine was not enough.
So we needed to create a high
performance domain for them.
But customization is a
little bit different.
These runs are short but very frequent.
So the runs could run anywhere
from one to four weeks
and you could have anywhere
between four and 10 cycles a year.
And there you often could
use heterogeneous compute.
So you might have P series
GPUs and G series with CPUs.
So you had to think about how
to scale up using containers.
Andrea will have a word
or two of about that
and how to use tools like Karpenter
and EKS to sort of scale up
a heterogeneous compute cluster.
And inference is completely different.
It's often spiky and sporadic,
even batch mode inference
goes on for a few hours,
let's say document
processing or summarization.
And these are often
loosely coupled workloads,
but depending on whether
it's real time batch mode,
you could have different
latency requirements.
So if you think of a mock example
of a chatbot, this is a
very simplistic example
of a chatbot producing one
output token at a time.
Of course now chatbots are
much more sophisticated,
but by and large input token lens
still happens to be higher.
So the initial portion,
the encoding portion
or the prefill portion is compute-bound.
And the intuition there is
you load the hyperparameters
from the HBM memory,
but depending on the length of the prompt,
you could essentially be using
the entire prompt computation
using those hyperparameters.
So you're essentially amortizing
the one time load operation
across a large context length.
But now if you go to the decoding portion,
it's the same intuition.
You load the hyperparameters
again from HBM memory,
but now you're processing
output one token at a time.
So you're amortizing that load operation
across one token at a time.
Of course it's simplistic now
you can have many more tokens
at a time and in fact
Shaunak will talk about
how they optimize the runtime layer.
And we are not done.
So think of memory capacity
as inference of course
some of the bigger models like Llama 4
and DeepSeek require at
least a P5E, if not P5EN,
which is our H200s.
So memory capacity becomes important.
But even for training, if you
think of pipeline parallelism,
if you're trying to compress
a model into a single GPU
and the memory is not enough,
you start getting into
pipeline parallelism
and the more pipeline
parallelism you have,
the less efficient memory usage you have.
So that starts hurting
performance as well.
But we're not done, some of the models,
especially mixture of
expert models, MOA models,
mixture of agents, some
of the multimodal models,
video processing of course,
some of the large frontier
models, they are network bound.
So we introduced a couple of years ago,
10p10u networking
and as a name suggests,
our goal is to deliver tens of petabytes
of non-blocking bandwidth
across tens of thousands of servers
in under 10 microseconds.
So this is something we
use UltraClusters for.
I keep pressing the wrong button.
UltraClusters for, and we will
talk about that in a second.
So this is the framework
I want to present.
When we think of scaling
on infrastructure,
we can either scale out so you
can add more and more servers
and clusters and UltraClusters,
which is Andreas topic.
Or you can scale up which is
if you have smaller models
or less than 10 billion parameter models.
But even if you have bigger models
and you want to kind of
homogenize your procurement
and you have a certain cluster
that you're purchasing,
which is Andre's domain, you can scale up.
So you can now go from
A100s to H100s to H200s
and now be Blackwells.
Or you can scale across
which is the inference stack.
And that depends on what
kind of models you have.
Is it distributed high performance
inferencing on the right
or single node GPUs on the left?
So I mentioned UltraClusters.
So this is in fact today when
Trainium 3 was announced,
we also announced UltraCluster 3.0.
Even UltraCluster 2.0
delivers 16x the bandwidth.
This is our way of managing
tens of thousands of GPUs,
or Trainium accelerators,
in one high speed domain.
So this becomes really important
when you are scaling out
to hundreds or even thousands of GPUs.
We have another paradigm
called UltraServer.
Last year you heard how we were able
to use UltraServer in a
single high-speed domain
of either 72 GPUs or 64
Trainium accelerators.
And this morning Matt
announced Trainium 3,
which is our way of
packing 144 Trainium chips
in one single high speed domain
that gives you five times
the performance per megawatt.
In terms of scaling up,
we have had a 15 year plus
partnership with NVIDIA.
We have been launching
instances almost every year
and over the last six months
the pace has increased
as you can see.
A couple of weeks ago we
announced a B300 base P6,
which delivers a whopping
6.4 terabytes per second
networking speed, 270
gigabytes of memory per GPU.
So this is the biggest
baddest GPU that we have.
But you can read the
specs on others as well.
We have GB200 based P6e.
A number of you should be using
Hopper-based instances as well.
And finally the stack,
we have the hardware layer,
which is what our team
primarily focuses on at AWS.
But on top of the hardware layer
we have many other abstraction layers,
right from security hypervisor using Nitro
to storage, to EFA networking
and then manage services like SageMaker.
So this is kind of the
framework I wanted to set
and now each speaker will
speak about their experiences
on kind of optimizing this
and in fact that this would be
the best part of the session
where you can hear from them.
We'll have Q and A.
We would love to devote
as much time as possible for the Q and A.
If you can hold onto
the questions till then,
it'll help us go through
the narrative first
and then we are open session after that
and we'll pass the mics
around for your questions.
Next up is Andrea, she's a Director at Arm
and she'll speak about her experiences.
- Great, okay. Hi, my name is Andrea.
I'm here from Arm where
I deal with some GPUs
and I have prior experience dealing
with a lot more GPUs at once.
The following advice is
really targeted at someone
who's dealing with a large number of GPUs
for the first time.
And so maybe you've had a few servers,
you've run a few experiments,
but a thousand GPUs kind
of sounds like a lot
and you don't really know what to do.
And if you have not really budgeted
for more than a few machines,
most of this you do not
need to worry about.
If on the other hand you
have raised like let's say
one to 10 to 100 billion
dollars seed round
and you're making a pre-training cluster
and this kind of thing also
this advice is not for you.
I'm gonna have a lot of
different suggestions for you.
But the basic idea is that
there are certain problems
that emerge predictably at scale for GPUs
and a thousand is about the line
where you cannot ignore them anymore.
And somewhere between 1,000
and 10,000 you will have
all of these problems and then
exciting new problems emerge
beyond that that we're going to ignore.
But do not worry, we are gonna solve
all of these problems in about 10 minutes.
And so just pay attention if this is you.
So for my sake, let's assume
you are my target audience
and you have money, the
money is not the problem.
You need to buy some GPUs
and you need to manage them.
And so this is great.
Congratulations, you now have a GPU farm,
but you do need to do
some planning in advance
and think about how you're
gonna handle these things.
And it's a little bit
harder than it looks,
especially if you've dealt
with a few machines before
and you think I know how to run GPUs
and everything is fine.
I think there are a few things
that are really important
to pay attention to at this scale.
The first thing is
you're adding more GPUs.
And so problems that happen
with GPUs happen more often,
but you're probably also adding
more jobs and larger jobs.
Larger jobs are big jobs
that use more GPUs at once.
And so when you have bigger jobs
and longer running jobs,
any problem is going
to occur more often.
It's more likely that your
workload gets disrupted
and fails and you need to be
very good at spotting this
and recovering from it.
And so at this scale you've
probably got a few different
use cases going on.
You may have multiple tenants
or customers who are sharing the capacity.
You may have different types of jobs,
maybe some are training
and some are inference
and some are doing something else.
And you think you've bought a lot of GPUs,
but if you ask your users,
you have not really bought that many.
And so very quickly all
of the workloads pile up
and are kind of demanding GPUs all at once
and you get yourself into some trouble.
The second thing is you're probably
with this type of machine
and this type of scale
doing some kind of distributed workloads,
probably distributed training,
maybe even distributed
or multi-node inference
since you kind of have to
pay attention to networking
and you have to pay attention
to distributed job
optimization and failures.
And finally, as I mentioned,
everything fails more often at scale
where failures become constant failures
and you have to worry about this.
And so don't lose all hope.
It's not that bad.
There are established ways of dealing
with these machines at this scale.
But I think before I talk about what to do
with your machines, I'm going
to consider the possibility
that you have not yet made
any purchasing decisions.
Maybe you just have money
but you don't have GPUs yet.
And if you're in that scenario
and you're seeing many nice slides
with many, many different types of GPUs
and accelerated instances,
it can get overwhelming
trying to decide what to pick.
But I think there are a
couple of rules of thumb
that are helpful.
One thing if it's not obvious is to try
and get all of your machines in one place.
And this is a little bit hard to do,
especially with constrained availability.
And maybe someone can offer
you a few on one coast
right away and a few in another place
and a few in another place
and that's fine, that's okay.
But then you're gonna do a
lot more work managing them
and your utilization is probably going
to be a lot lower if you
have a fragmented system.
And so given the option,
especially for newer GPUs,
I recommend either at the beginning
or kind of pre-negotiated over time
to consolidate your capacity
into a single location.
And increasingly for modern
GPUs is doesn't not just mean
one region or one zone
which you can run with one control plane.
It means one physical UltraCluster built
or equivalently one networking spine.
And so try and get your machines
of one type in the same physical cluster
with very fast interconnect
kind of all in one place.
We may discuss this later,
but you have a broad
selection of instance types
and it can be tempting to
hyper optimize your machines
to your workloads because
maybe you have many different
workloads and you benchmark them all
and one is faster on one machine
and one is faster on another machine,
but you run a bit the
same fragmentation risk
trying to get greedy and get capacity
wherever you can get it right away.
If you try and get a
super optimized machine
for each workload, you may
not have consistent traffic
to keep all your machines
busy all the time.
And so I tend to toward what
I call workhorse machines,
machines that are fast enough
and you have a lot of the same thing
that they can handle most of your traffic
and remain consistently busy.
And so if you manage this,
you make a choice, maybe one
or two accelerated instances,
and all in one place,
there are a lot of ways
to manage capacity,
but I think it's a fairly
safe recommendation
that at this scale you
should think about running
your own clusters and that you
should do so with Kubernetes.
I think it's also fairly safe to say
that for the majority of use
cases there's no major downside
to using a managed
Kubernetes service like EKS.
I think there are exceptions to that
but you kind of have to
a reason not to use it
as opposed to a reason to justify it.
And so this will simplify
your cluster management a lot
and I think there are some good practices
about how to set up your cluster
that we'll look at in a moment
with an example diagram.
But you should kind of
standardize your cluster.
All your machines should be
on the same versions of things
so all your jobs can
run on all your machines
and tend to have the same
dependencies and same failures.
And you should do something
to deal with GPU failures,
which we'll talk about more as well.
So here's the diagram I promised
and it's just an example.
You may have a slightly different setup,
but there are a couple of things
that I want to draw your attention to.
The first thing is that you have somehow
got your machines all in one place.
And so there is only one
account in this diagram,
there's only one cluster
and all the machines are in one
cluster, which is very nice.
The second thing to notice
is that there's a mysterious scheduling
or orchestration component
implied in the cluster
other than the built-in
Kubernetes scheduler.
And again, there's a lot of selection
and we'll look at some
options for this in a moment.
But especially for batch computing,
I think it's broadly
accepted that Kubernetes
is not really going to have
all the scheduling properties
that you want for AI workloads
and you're probably
going to end up layering
something on top to manage
the way your workloads
are scheduled to machines.
The third thing to
notice is the node pools.
This is deliberately vague.
It could be autoscaling groups,
it could be managed node
groups of some kind,
but they're divided up.
The machines are not all
in one giant pool somehow.
So probably in Kubernetes
they've got different labels
or taints and workloads
are kind of pointed
at one node pool or another.
There's some CPU only capacity in there.
Don't forget to budget for that.
You will probably need it.
There's a couple different types of GPU,
they're in different node pools
with maybe different driver versions.
And you can see
that in this scenario there's
been more than one GPU
procured for the batch use case.
There's some P5s and P6Cs
and those are in different node pools
and kept logically separate.
Workloads are either going to one
or they're going to the other.
And if you do end up combining some
kind of realtime inference use case
with offline batch processing,
which there can also be reasons not to do,
but if you do do that,
I think at least have
some kind of logical barrier
between the realtime capacity
and the offline processing capacity.
And finally, I'm not
gonna make a sales pitch
for any particular storage technology,
but planning out your storage hierarchy
is gonna be a really important part
of planning your cluster.
It does help that the newer
GPU instances increasingly
come with a lot of built-in
SSD in the form of NVME,
especially P5 and definitely P6e.
And so that is your first bet
and best bet for storage
during things like training.
It's very fast and it is very free
and it is built into the machines.
But inevitably that is not a
durable place to store anything
that you care about long term.
And so probably there's some
other storage in the picture
that's keeping longer term
records of training data
and checkpoints or data that
your workloads are processing
while they run in the cluster.
And so finally it is just
a bit implied by this
that you need to budget
for things other than GPUs.
So I pointed out there's some
CPU only machines in there,
so do not forget these.
There's some storage, do not
forget to budget for storage.
And then finally these
things talk to each other.
And so there is definitely
some networking traffic
likely to be happening here
unless all of your data
is inside the UltraCluster never leaving,
probably there's some data flow in and out
and so don't forget to plan
for and budget for networking.
So I mentioned scheduling
and orchestration.
You probably need to make some choices
beyond just turning up Kubernetes
and deciding that you're done.
For batch jobs, there's a
longer list of quality tools
than I can list.
And so I don't want to sell
you on any particular one
but I think anyone who tells you
that there is a perfect scheduler
for all workloads is a
little bit suspicious.
You should really evaluate a
range for what you're doing.
And if you're looking at
hosting serving workloads,
you're probably looking at
a different set of tools
than someone who's doing
mostly batch processing.
And so when you're thinking
through the options,
especially at this scale,
1,000 GPUs is not as much as it sounds.
And if the size of your
large jobs is anywhere
within an order of magnitude
of the size of your cluster,
if you do not have something
that does gang scheduling
on top of Kubernetes,
your jobs are gonna deadlock very fast.
And you'll have two or
three that are half started
and nothing goes and the
whole system locks up.
And so you definitely cannot
ignore this at this scale
for this type of workload.
In addition to scheduling,
you need to worry a little
bit about resource management.
You are definitely going to
have a range of workloads
and probably a range of tenants
fighting over this capacity.
And all you can really do is
have some kind of a policy
that everyone has agreed to
that the system enforces on their behalf.
And whatever tool that ends up making
your scheduling decisions probably also
has something to say
about your resource management decisions.
And so you need to look at your interest
in both of those properties
when you choose that tool.
And then finally, most of
these things are fairly solid
but you should look not just in principle
how those scheduling works
and what promises it makes in the docks,
but also make sure that it can handle
the load in the traffic
that you expect in the
system when it's live.
'Cause the scheduling will
be a single point of failure
for your system.
And then I will give a
special shout out to GB200.
And so if you're dealing
with any rack scale capacity
like GB200 or upcoming GB300,
at this point you really cannot
avoid dealing with topology
in your choice of scheduler.
Most likely some workloads
have some constraints,
maybe multi-node workload
needs to go to the same rack
or big training workload needs
to use several whole racks
in training as you also need
to choose a scheduling component
that can express that the way you want.
Finally, observability, if
you have spent all this money
and bought all these GPUs, you better know
what is going on with them.
And this is partially for your own sanity
so you can tell if the system is working.
Is partially for your users sanity
so they can tell if it's working
and they can also tell how busy it is.
And finally it is also
for what I will refer to
as the powers that be people
who maybe have a financial
interest in what you are doing
with all the money and all of the GPUs.
And by the time they come asking
what your utilization looks like,
ideally you should already know.
And so these are kind of made up diagrams
just to give a sense of things.
But there are a couple of things I think
you should really monitor in real time
and for long periods of time
so that you always have this information.
You should know how much
of your capacity appears
to be working and you should
know how much of it is used
by end user workloads,
what kind of scheduling
utilization you're getting.
And then depending on your use case
you should have some notion
of live traffic to the system.
The graph shown is for
something like a batch system
that has queue jobs and running jobs.
And this also is very
entertaining to people
who wanna know why their job is queued
and whether the queue is very long.
Over longer periods of time,
not necessarily in real time,
but maybe on a daily or weekly basis,
I really recommended the
scale having some notion
of how responsible your
end users are being.
And so some notion of workload efficiency
that catches if workloads
are requesting GPUs
that they never use
or running with a really
low average utilization
or have really wonky
resource configurations
is a great idea.
We'll let you catch
these things out quicker
before they tank your overall metrics.
And then finally you should
know how the computing time
or the cost in the system is being spent
between your tenants or your use cases
and have some kind of
monitoring or show backs.
And with this I'm gonna
pass it off to Henri,
who's going to talk about
his lived experience
in this domain.
(audience clapping)
- Hi, my name's Henri
and I wish I had heard
Andrea's talk a few years ago
because I was the target audience.
So what I'm gonna do is
walk you through some of our
sort of learned experience
scaling AI compute
for lab in the loop.
And I'll start
by giving you a brief overview
of what I'm talking about.
So I work in AI for drug discovery
and what we do is make
machine learning models
to design molecules.
And when we talk about lab
in the loop, what you mean
is essentially you start
with some experimental data
and train machine learning
models on it, use those models
to come up with new potential
molecules in our case
and then make those run
experiments, get new data
that hopefully feeds back into the models
and eventually by iterating
you reach the level of quality
of your molecules that you're hoping for.
Or at least that's the dream.
And on the right, this
is just an example of
one class of molecules that we
worked on called antibodies.
We were optimizing across expression,
how easy they are to make in Affinity
and sort of you can see
over subsequent rounds
we're kind of pushing the
Pareto frontier forward,
which is what you're hoping
to do in this kind of process.
And so in order for this to work,
one of the things that you need
is good machine learning models.
And nowadays in order to
have state-of-the-art models,
what that means is training
large models on multiple nodes.
And in particular I'll focus
on one of the kinds of models
that we've been working
on which are these LLMs
in the like 70 billion parameter range.
I guess those still count as large
and very briefly on our infrastructure.
So we have our GPUs on parallel cluster,
which is one of the schedulers
that Andrea was talking about.
And most of our long-term
data storage is an S3.
And so by scaling up our
model size and compute,
we ran into all of the
following challenges.
The first one are hardware faults.
When you're working on one
machine, one node, a few GPUs,
typically you don't run into this
but at scale they're inevitable.
I think we ran into these
as soon as we were scaling
it across tens of nodes.
And these are typically seen as,
you know, the training job
crashing with unclear reasons.
And so in order to sort of solve this,
what we did was test the nodes.
There are a variety of
different ways you can do this.
In the end we sort of run a
very simple PyTorch script
on a new node, make sure that it's able
to use the GPUs, load data on the GPU
and run simple calculations
and then remove bad ones.
A trick here that took us a little while
to figure out is just
because you evict a node,
you might actually just get it back,
especially when you start worrying
about challenge number
two, which is networking.
So with networking these
are typically really hard
to debug errors.
You don't often have clear reasons why
some networking error happens
or can see it in the logs.
We usually saw these as Nickel timeouts
and what we found was really helpful
is really try to avoid hops.
So if you can avoid cross zone traffic
or even cross spine networking
you can get much better stability
and also better performance.
But in one spine there's
only so much capacity,
that's why this issue of
getting back the same node
can happen.
And the final challenge is
around the model implementation
and this is something
that's really fully under your control.
One strategy that really
helped us was carefully testing
the various libraries used.
So CUDA your EFA kernel
if you're using, you know,
PE instances as well as, you know,
Nickel, OFI, plugins and things like that.
All of these are really brittle
and making sure that you
test all of the versions
that you're gonna run together
and sort of upgrade them
altogether will lead
to tremendous improvements
in your stability.
On the data loading side,
the common challenge is really
feeding data fast enough
to the GPUs so that you can
get that good utilization
and this is sort of the
most common source of bugs
that I see when machine
learning scientists come to me
with bad GPU efficiency.
This is also sort of a Python problem
because in order to load
data quickly you need
to have multiple threads,
multiple processes,
this is notoriously finicky in Python.
And spending a lot of time
stress testing your data loaders
is really useful.
On the checkpointing side,
no matter what you do there
will be failures for your models
and so being able to checkpoint
and resume is critical
and that will really help you save
sort of wasted compute.
And lastly we found that as you
start training larger models
moving away from abstractions
and libraries that sort of wrap PyTorch,
to sort of native
PyTorch helped us improve
the efficiency and the stability.
And so putting these in practice,
here's some charts of our GPU utilization.
So if you don't have the pleasure
in your day-to-day job of staring
at GPU utilization charts,
I feel sorry for you, they're pretty fun.
But also what you're
looking at here essentially
on the Y axis is the percent average.
GPU utilization...
Is everyone okay there?
Average GP utilization percent
for a LLM training job.
And you can see a couple issues
with the one on the left.
The first one is sort
of low GP utilization.
We're around mid 60 to a mid 60%.
That means you know if you
are running on 100 GPUs
sort of 40 or 35 of them are
not being utilized on average.
The other issue we see here are these
sort of pauses every
couple tens of minutes
where the GPU utilization drops to zero
and this is often a symptom
of sort of checkpointing
where everything is
stopping, stop the world,
you're writing to disc all of
the weights and then resuming.
And the other thing we can see here is
sort of relatively short training runs
on the order of several hours.
This is because we had
some stability issues.
And so by implementing
some of the improvements
and addressing some of
the challenges I mentioned
in the previous slide,
distributed checkpointing,
really investing in our data loading,
and dropping down to fully
sharded data parallel,
we're able to really bring up
our GP utilization to sort of
where you want to be, you know mid 90%.
This is the chart I wanna
show to the powers that be
how good we are at using our
GPUs and not the previous one.
Of course using your GPUs is not enough,
it's really important to use them in ways
that are effective.
And so for us we run
varying types of compute
but I showed here two major ones.
So on the left it's
molecular dynamic simulation,
how long it takes to generate
a one nanosecond trajectory.
And here less is better so
you want to take less time
to generate that one nanosecond.
And what you can see
it's kind of interesting,
an L40S takes about as long as a B200
to run this compute, this is just one GPU.
Which, you know, L40S is relatively old
or very old I guess in GPU generation time
it's three years old versus the B200
which is pretty recent.
And so that means, you know, if you have
a lot of specific kinds of workloads
you should really benchmark them
to see if it's worth considering
having dedicated compute
and tuning the architecture for that.
On the LLM training side, this is sort of
what you see in all of
the releases of new chips.
We saw very similar results
where you get more tokens per second
which is good on newer GPUs.
Yeah so tying it all together, you know,
thanks to some of our efforts in
optimizing our LLM training,
really now we're working on
having intention aware
agents that are trained
on all of our internal data
so they understand drug discovery,
they understand our models
and what we're working towards
is having these agents,
you know, be able to
translate some requirements.
So in this case the example
I'm giving you is this phase
in drug discovery that's
called lead optimization
where you have a molecule
and you're trying to
improve certain properties.
And so the idea is you ask your agent,
"Can you improve these properties?"
And the agent can translate
that into a workflow,
you know, run these generative
models that we have,
these property prediction models
that we have that are able
to identify specific aspects
of the molecule and then rank
and filter those, maybe run
through a few loops of that
and ultimately then we can
send that for synthesis
to the wet lab and look at the predicted
and real output and sort of compare.
And so in order for this
agentic loop to work,
what you need is to have
all of your models deployed.
So we use Kubernetes to run those
and sort of some agentic
framework to tie it together.
And that's how we've really been working
on speeding drug development process
and trying to improve the
success rate of our R and D.
Yeah and with that I'll
hand it off to Shaunak
for more information about agents.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Henri.
So as Henri was describing,
the most successful agents that are built
are built using models
that are trained on the data
that your enterprises have.
And that's what I'm going
to talk a little bit about.
We call it artificial
autonomous intelligence,
which basically essentially
means you own your data
so you should essentially own your models
and own your deployments as well.
I'm Shaunak, I'm the
field CTO at Fireworks
we specialize in inferencing
as well as training for
a lot of open models.
So I think 2025 is the year of agents
I should say or the year of agents.
I think almost all of you must have used
one of these agents, specifically
Cursor or Sourcegraph.
They're all are in like the coding space,
you have a bunch of them
in like the document processing space.
You're seeing a lot of
like enterprises show up
that are doing legal processing,
healthcare processing,
FSNI and those types of stuff.
Everybody's building one
or these types of agents.
And so the agents on the
top are some of the ones
that have like really picked up this year
but we feel and we have observed
that there are many, many more
that are actually being built out
and we feel that these
are the agents that will
sort of be more pervasive
this year as well.
So when you think about like agents,
I think there are two main
principles that we think about
and both of these principles
are based on the fact
that your data is the most
precious commodity that you have
and the models that are
generally available do not align
with the data that exists
in your enterprises.
Especially because they have
been trained on public data
or they have been trained on data
that is synthetically
generated by a few companies.
And so what we have realized
is the first principle
is don't treat your model as a commodity.
Your model is your product.
It needs to be built using data flywheel.
I think Henri gave a great example of
how they built out their
models by iteratively training
and are like constantly
improving the model
using the data flywheel that they have.
And then the second one
is, in the same lines,
your model is your IP, right?
Your model and your product
needs to work together
to provide your users with
the best user experience
that they can have.
So the overall principles,
your model and your product
should coexist and your model is your IP.
Do not treat it as a commodity.
Now when you think about
models, when you think about
this infrastructure,
when you think about like
where LLMs are, there are so many choices.
So I'll give you a little bit of overview
over the next couple of slides
about the different types
of choices you can make,
whether they are regards to models
or whether they are
regards to infrastructure.
So models now come in
different types of modalities.
You have text, you have image,
you have image generation,
you have video generation,
you have embeddings et cetera.
You have different types
of model providers.
All of them have like
different expertise, right?
So you have model, sorry, you
have Amazon, you have Meta,
you have DeepSeek, you have
Qwen, Qwen's from Alibaba
and they have all been
showing signs of catching up
with the proprietary
or different tier models
that you see today.
And of course like there
are lots of model sizes,
I'm specifically talking here about LLMs
or large language models.
So they range anywhere from
1B, even smaller for some
of the embedding models,
all the way to 1 trillion,
which is the latest model
that you saw from this
company called Kimi,
which is roughly a
trillion parameters long.
After you choose the model,
the next one is model alignment
based on the data that you have.
Again, many, many choices here.
The first one is supervise fine tuning
where you give your models
a few set of examples
to sort of align the model.
Then you have DPO where
you give it positive
and negative samples.
And then you have
reinforcement fine tuning
where you have a reward
function that tries
to align your model based
on the data that you have.
The last one is sort of the one
that now almost all the frontier labs
and these open model
companies actually use
to improve the quality of the
model because it's cheaper
and it gives you like really good results.
And then the last one is
talking a little bit about
serving those models.
So we talk about like the
inference infrastructure.
There are lots of trade offs here.
Typically you have three things,
your inference can be better,
it can be faster, it can be cheaper.
And most of the companies
have like one choice
or two choices.
And we can also talk about
a little bit after this
that can you actually make trade off
on all the three choices?
Then you have a security
constraint, right?
Whether this model and
deployments should be SaaS based,
should they run in your own private PPC?
Should they run in on-prem?
Do you have legal approvals to use models?
Are these models properly
penetrated, tested,
and so on and so forth.
So with that, let's move to the next one
which is I'll talk a little bit about like
the inference infrastructure
Andrea covered
that you have for
inference infrastructure.
You have different types of
serving stack for bad jobs,
different types of serving
stack for real time jobs.
And so the next few slides
we'll talk a little bit
about when you have your own deployments,
how do you think about
which things to use?
So the first one is pick the hardware.
There are so many of them, right?
There's accelerated compute,
you have AWS, you have NVIDIA
providing you GPUs, you
have what we call here
Ampere series, Hopper
series, Blackwell series.
And as of today Trainium
has Trainium 3 as well.
All of these hardwares have like
different trade offs to make.
I think Aniruddha covered a
lot of them as part of a stock.
Some have huge amounts of FLOPS,
some have lots of memory per GPU.
Some have really good inter
GPU connects et cetera.
So once you sort of pick the hardware,
you pick the hardware provider
and then you have to start thinking about
optimizing your inference engine.
You typically have few
choices that have listed out,
these are the most common
ones, but you have many more.
You typically think about model charting.
If your model is very large
it might not fit on a single GPU.
You have to shard it across different GPU.
You have disaggregated serving.
This is where you separate out
the two phases of generation,
which is the prefill
and the generation step.
This type of techniques
are very, very common
especially in agent TKI systems
where your inputs are extremely long
but your outputs are structured
and very short JSON outputs.
Then you think about which
inference kernel to use.
There are many of them.
I think TRT-LLM has done a great job
or NVIDA has done a great
job of like providing
a bunch of like inference kernels.
vLLM, SGLang have all created
like Flash Infer, Flash
Attention, et cetera,
which are like doing really well.
Then you think about cross serving.
So what if your model is so large
that it doesn't fit on
a single GPU machine?
Then you actually have
to shard the model across
like different types of hosts.
When you do that, you need like really
good communication to happen.
So Amazon here does a great
job of providing us with EFA
where the speed of transfer
of KV cache from like
one machine to another
is like really, really quick.
And that essentially helps
with faster generation,
faster throughputs.
Speculative decoding is one
of the most commonly used
techniques that allows you to
train a very, very small model
that just speculates
and the larger model
instead of generating,
just realizes or just
checks whether the token
that's generated is
actually correct or not.
So once you've finalized the
inferencing engine options,
you then have to move to serving stack.
Andrea already covered a lot
of this in her Kubernetes talk
around like horizontal scaling,
but I'll talk a little bit more deeply
about specifics to inference.
So you have prompt caching,
which is one of the most
common techniques now
that's used if you have
like the same system prompts
that get used, what kind of system
that is provided by like the
inference engine, et cetera.
So you can use like prompt caching.
Second one is session affinity.
Very, very useful if you
have coding types of agents
that you're building or that you're using
so that the same request
goes to the same machine.
In these types of cases,
the reliability of machines
is extremely, extremely important.
And so using something like EKS
that's actually managed.
Using Amazon, which is extremely reliable
and extremely available is super important
because then the failures
around session affinity
or your prompt dropping
reduces significantly.
Then you have request
failover, load shedding,
these are typically the cases when you
sort of get like spikes
of traffic or you have
or you want to fail over
to like another region.
So once you have picked
out your serving stack,
you then have to move to
global secure serving, right?
So Andrea talked a
little bit about what if,
try to get your GPUs in one
region as much as possible,
but sometimes it is not possible
or sometimes you might need
to have cross region traffic
or you might need to have regionality
and so you use global
secure serving in that case.
You need to have some
sort of global scheduling.
You need to have private
PPCs for secure serving.
You might even want to do
things like Private-Link
so that your data never
leaves your VPC boundary.
And all of these are
provided by Amazon's ELB systems
or through Amazon's Private-Link.
And that's where we are
seeing a lot of prevalence
of secure and compliant infrastructure.
So that was a very high level of like
what the inference stacks are.
So this is how we actually
built our inference stack,
taking all of these into account.
And so today Fireworks serves about,
I think this is a little old,
maybe like a few weeks old,
about 150,000 requests per second.
We process more than 13
trillion tokens a day.
We have bunch of models
across different modalities
and we host on private secure cloud.
And we have a booth.
Our booth number is 1588.
So please come and talk to us
if you're interested in
learning about any of this.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Aniruddha] Please, please
do prepare a lot of questions.
We really hope you guys ask
the best questions of all.
Please do fill out a survey from your app.
This really helps us raise
the bar at future events
and the more number of
people sign up the survey,
the better data we get in terms
of figuring out what worked,
what didn't work, and
what needs to improve.
So any questions, any burning
questions on how to scale AI?